- Hello and good afternoon, everybody.
- There you go.
- My name is Kam Amir.
I am with Cribl.
I will be taking over for Chris O'Brien.
And with me I have Ed Bailey.
- Hey, thank you very much.
My name's Ed Bailey.
I'm Cribl's field CISO.
I just wanna say,
we're really missing Chris not being here.
He had a family emergency
and so Chris, we're thinking
the best thoughts for you.
But he will be here in spirit.
We will try to sound
sophisticated, as you do,
but we will fail, but we'll try our best.
But thank you, everyone, for being here.
- Yes. Thank you again.
And for this session,
we're gonna talk about
how Sophos used Cribl
to modernize their data security
for their AWS data and other data sources.
So first things first, just
kind of put the agenda out here.
We're gonna talk about the
challenges that they faced,
the solution they came up with,
the outcomes that came from
this solution together,
lessons learned, best practices.
We're gonna do the best we can,
obviously channeling our
best Chris impression.
Quick demonstration, and
then questions and answers.
So please feel free to ask
us some questions at the end.
- So to tell you a
little bit about Sophos.
Sophos is a company
with an enormous footprint
across the world,
specializes in MDR, analysts and coverage,
600,000 customers,
just unbelievable wave of data.
And where Cribl comes in
is to help secure the infrastructure,
help secure the software,
help give Sophos the
ability to control costs,
but also provide better solutions.
So it's really important,
this is for a key global company,
and just one of the more phenomenal
security vendors out there.
- Absolutely. And about Cribl.
So Cribl is a late-stage startup.
We've been around for about seven years.
We have roughly, you know,
a thousand-plus employees.
We've been in the data
space for quite a while.
We kind of pioneered this data pipeline,
telemetry data solution.
And we're backed by a lot of
leading venture capital firms.
- So the challenges that we all had was,
I mean, the exponential telemetry growth.
I mean, we see for most companies,
you know, 28, 30% is common.
Sophos, it's more like 60.
So much data.
And that generates a corresponding amount
of data coming off the systems
that needs to be collected,
needs to be secured,
for observability and security.
And just an incredible
diversity of sources as well.
You know, every cloud, every endpoint,
so many types of data.
And this is something we see
in the IT and security space,
it's the wave of data,
it's the diversity of data.
It's all coming out of there.
And finally, then cost.
And then just the legacy tool
sets just cannot keep up.
Sophos tried very, very hard
to build its own set of tools,
collection of commercial,
collection of open source.
And the engineering
cost wasn't sustainable,
the cost of SIEM wasn't sustainable,
the storage cost wasn't sustainable,
and they needed to look
for something different.
And this is where Sophos
then came to Cribl
to start looking for something new
and a way to solve these challenges.
- And this is a story
that we at Cribl have
heard many, many a time.
From what we see in the industry,
roughly 30% CAGR, year
of year growth of data.
Telemetry data is primarily
what we're talking about here,
logs, metrics, traces.
And there's also a
additional component here
where AI is starting to kind
of kick up even more data
that's being generated at scale.
And both of those are
kind of leading the charge
as far as how much data
is being generated.
But everybody's budget
typically doesn't grow
at the same rate.
What we're seeing is
that the major difference
between what the data growth looks like
and what their budgets
look like is significant.
And that's kind of where Cribl is found.
- Yeah, but add onto to that,
I mean, this is something
that we see a lot.
This has been going on
for quite some time.
The oldest conundrum in IT and security
is I got two terabytes of license
and 10 terabytes of data.
How do I make this work?
I never forget, just
before I discovered Cribl
completely by accident in 2018,
I get pulled into a meeting with my CIO
complaining about, "Well,
you're spending so much money."
And I thought I was doing pretty good
containing costs around 30%
when my login volume was growing 200%.
And the irony was, I'd
just come from a meeting
with a bunch of VPs complaining
about I wasn't giving them
enough data to do their job.
And so this is something we feel deeply,
we see everyone's out there
because, you know, you need more data,
you need to meet all the challenges,
but how do you maintain the cost?
And that was something that
was just really unique,
was being able to thread the needle
between manage your data,
but also have better quality.
Because at the end of the day,
high-quality data solves problems.
Less data doesn't solve problems.
Good data is what solves problems.
And that's where Cribl comes in.
- And that's kind of where Sophos came in
and started to see the value of Cribl.
- Right
- And with that,
they're able to start
to see these kind of-
- Exactly. And then the
modernization was huge.
Being able to start
replacing piece by piece.
Displacement costs are a
huge issue in any enterprise.
You have some vendor
that comes in and says,
"Yeah, you gotta replace
all that stuff right away.
You gotta install our agent everywhere."
And the cost of installing the agents,
like for me, you know, early on,
if I had had to put Cribl
agent on 200,000 endpoints,
it would not have happened.
But instead I was able to
start simply by the idea
of I could put a couple hundred
Stream servers in place,
use the sources I already
have, and start getting value
and then grow my footprint over time.
So now I can manage my displacement costs
and get fast value.
And later on you'll see
just how completely
transformative that was.
And when Sophos then put Stream in place
and then they started to push
the Cribl Edge agent out,
a piece at a time.
So they were able to then manage the cost,
but still get value from
the entire solution.
And then they started working
for optimizing for volume and cost.
This is where I think data
tiering is incredibly important.
You always have to think about
that, "Here's my data set,"
and this is where people get in trouble
with monolithic SIEM vendors
is you have to put all your
data in the same place.
Typically, your SIEM is gonna run you
about a dollar a gig.
And you have to always ask yourself,
"Does all the data in my SIEM,
is it worth a dollar a gig?"
And more often than not,
that's not the case.
So you always have to look at,
you know, is it worth a dollar a gig?
And if it's not worth a dollar a gig,
we need to start looking at
putting it somewhere else.
You work with a lot of customers.
What do you see especially
with data tiering solutions?
That makes sense, you
know, for most customers.
- Absolutely. I mean it starts with
the legacy solutions
that they have in place.
So we back up a little bit
and say, "Look, I have a
bunch of Syslog servers."
How many of you love
going into Syslog servers
and modify configuration
files multiple times?
That's not exactly what I call a fun job.
So here, Cribl can kind
of put itself in place
to help fix that one problem.
And then slowly look at your WEF.
If you're trying to
collect Windows events:
WEF, WEC, that's a joy to do.
"Oh, I got the wrong certificate,
the wrong configuration set up."
So here's another solution
that Cribl can come help with.
And piece by piece,
when you start putting
these things together,
then you can start going down the path of,
now that I have all the data that I need,
or at least, a subset of the data,
I can start optimizing that data.
So all the debug files,
all the debug logs,
all the things that are generating
so much waste in my SIEM
and so much waste in my infrastructure,
I can start to, you know, tune that out
and make it so that I'm
getting way more signal
than I am noise.
And that's where we start
to see a big plus for Cribl.
- And that's a key piece.
By having Stream in the middle,
being able to understand,
okay, this is my detection event,
this is my IR event, this
is my compliance event.
Being able to understand your data
and then route accordingly gives
you that power to now scale
so that you can make sure
that, "Hey, you know,
we're gonna drive the best quality data,
we're gonna power our
detections, get the best results,
but still maintain control,
have all the other data."
I think last night I
thought I put it really well
with the idea that there's
the data you have to have,
there's the data you might want,
and there's the data you don't want,
but you have to take it anyway.
- Yep.
- Split it up like that.
Start using Stream, then
start putting the data
where it starts matching cost and value.
And so then that way you can then focus on
how do I get more value from my SIEM?
And this is another
big project for Sophos,
was migrating off their SIEM.
SIEM's are risky.
You see it all the time where
companies will routinely,
you know, come to us, you
know, we spent a year,
we spent two years trying
to migrate to a SIEM.
We started problems we couldn't migrate.
Now we have two SIEMs, we don't like this.
And this is the thing that the idea
about Stream was so powerful.
This is something I discovered early on.
This is the same thing with Sophos.
The idea of my data's coming through,
I can put a copy of my
data to my legacy SIEM,
I don't disrupt my
posture, nothing changes.
Then I fork a copy of that
data over to my new SIEM.
So now you have the
entire production volume
going to your new SIEM.
You can now start building your content.
You can now start validating.
Did my legacy SIEM get a hit?
Did my new SIEM get a hit?
You know, back and forth, back and forth
to make sure that your content works.
This is a underappreciated issue.
SIEMs are complicated, you gotta validate.
You have to cover your Edge cases.
You need more data.
So having Stream in place
makes that possible.
And we just recently with
a really insurance company,
they were on a legacy SIEM
provider for about 10 years.
We helped them migrate
to a next gen SIEM option
in about five months.
This is something that previously
just would not have been possible.
And so we were so proud to then bring this
and help Sophos do the same.
Anything you wanna add about that?
- Oh, absolutely. So a lot of the times
when you're talking
about a SIEM migration,
you talk about this hard cutover, right?
Where you're saying, "Okay,
I'm on my legacy SIEM
and now I'm gonna go to a new SIEM."
- Yeah, the vaya con dios moment.
- Oh yes.
- Yes.
- Oh yes. So all of a sudden
you turn on their agents,
their collection things and
going on and none of the
detections work.
- Exactly.
- None of the dashboards light up
and now you're kind of up
some creek without a paddle.
Here, with Cribl, you're, you know,
forking the data across multiple SIEMs.
Actually we had a couple customers
that have tried multiple SIEMs in a POC
to pick the one that actually
worked best for them.
So again, giving you that
choice and control of your data,
you can see that in any SIEM
that you want to try out.
And it leads to customers
having a much more satisfied
approach to getting their SIEM
and then being able to cut
over to it in a very soft
and kind of easy manner.
- Yeah, we've had a number
of customers that will...
they'll cut over to the new SIEM
but they'll leave the
data to the old SIEM going
like 1Ciso just like, I wanna
see what happens for 30 days.
I wanna make sure that we
didn't forget something.
And it was really powerful
'cause at the end of the day,
when they're ready, it literally
go to a button inside a
Stream, you turn it off
and you're done, and it
makes that transition
to a new platform so much easier.
It's easier in your teams.
It takes the risk away.
And also from a cost
perspective, it's not unheard of.
You know, even for a
small SIEM implementation,
you're gonna be paying,
you know, a million a year.
And the idea is that...
I'm not gonna be able to get value
from my SIEM implementation
for 8, 9, 10 months, a year.
So that's an entire million dollars,
potentially, you're not
getting any value from.
And being able to accelerate
that process to say,
go to, you know, five
months instead of a year,
you're now recovering that money,
you're now recovering that
value for your company.
- Yeah, especially if you're
talking about the AR model now.
Before it was like, okay,
I paid for a license,
I got that license, I could
let it sit on the shelf.
If I buy a SIEM now, I
have three years at least,
maybe a year to get that
thing to be valuable for me.
So if I can accelerate that
so that I can actually start
getting value from it from day one.
And thankfully with Cloud,
it makes it a lot faster,
'cause I remember the days
with Splunk where you had
to go set up indexers, set up searches
and do that fun dance.
Here you have everything
running in the cloud.
Only thing you're missing is
getting the data to the SIEM.
Now we accelerate that,
you start seeing value,
your boss sees value, your
boss's boss sees value.
Suddenly that investment in the SIEM
and investment in Cribl is well paid for.
- Right. And that's why we
always talk about the idea
of solving problems with better data.
You know, options. That's where
choice to control comes in.
And this, it's an important concept.
So, but always remember the
idea about data tiering,
matching cost and value,
and then de-risking your SIEM migration.
There's nothing worse than
being stuck with a SIEM
that you don't want.
And so this is the idea, is
make it a modular component,
gives you a lot more options
at the end of the day.
- And now here's kind of
the way that it all happens.
So what I'm gonna show you,
this is our portfolio for Cribl.
We have Edge
that effectively sits over
here on the source side.
So if you have an agent, great,
you can still use your agent
to get data into Cribl.
We can also use Edge, which
is kind of a replacement
for an agent to get
that same data transited
through Cribl Stream or
directly to your destination.
Then in the middle is our
flagship product, Cribl Stream.
This is where the magic happens.
We effectively are using that
to collect data from sources,
any typical protocol we
can collect the data from.
We can then transform it, route
it to multiple destinations,
enrich it.
We can also look for PII
and if there's any sensitive
data, take it out, encrypt it,
so that it doesn't land in your SIEM.
Great story about that one.
We had a very large company
that was sending PII
to their SIEM, big, no-no.
And they had to basically go back,
take the data out of their
SIEM, this was a fun one,
replay it with Cribl
after they sanitized it,
Cribl was able to sanitize the
data, put it back into SIEM,
everybody was happy,
compliance was restored.
- What a nightmare.
- I know.
And then the other two
components here, very briefly,
we do have a Lake offering.
So this allows you to basically leverage
object storage at scale
with your organization,
with built-in role-based access control.
This makes it so that
lighting up an S3 bucket
is typically fun in an organization
where you have to ask
for the right policy,
the right roles, the
right retention policies,
All of that's built into Cribl Lake.
We also have the ability to accelerate
that data in Cribl Lake with Lakehouse.
So you have fast search.
And finally, you have
Cribl Search, which kind of
is the umbrella across
all of these components
that allows you to query the
data at rest, through APIs,
a lot of very fun things.
We actually have a new
integration with Security Hub,
so come by our booth, we'll
tell you more about it.
- And so how Sophos is
using the Cribl portfolio,
starting with Edge, and this is...
I've managed thousands, I
mean, tens of thousands,
probably close to a million
agents in my career.
Managing agents is a true pain.
There's probably few
things that waste more time
than trying to manage agents at scale.
And what I just love about Edge is
it centralizes all that complexity.
Get it installed. You now
have a policy based way
to manage everything from the same place.
You can upgrade it, monitor
it, understand your data,
you can customize it, add
scripts, do everything you need,
all from one place.
Gives you scale, it gives you ease of use.
And most importantly, when I
was an engineering manager,
the idea is that how you can then...
you know, I can have
junior people manage this.
I don't need someone senior who's managed,
who's figured out the
YAML syntax of the day.
Just make it easy, give you
what you need, get your data,
and move your engineering
time off your endpoints
and move your engineering time
to getting value from your data.
Also using Cribl Stream, so
Cribl Stream in the middle.
So Cribl Stream is getting all the data,
all the sources, including from Edge
and then giving that ability
to now parse, enrich,
tier this data, route this data
as we share it across the enterprise.
This is something at the end
as we start going through
our demo is to start showing
the value of sharing data
throughout the enterprise.
I think that's really underappreciated.
Every time that you share data,
you're not compounding the value.
Take something as prosaic as firewall logs
can help solve problems
for the SOC, the NOC,
or DevOps team, your
network engineering team.
You may laugh, but you would
be surprised how oftentimes
network engineers don't have
access to their own logs.
And so these are the kind of
things by just share data,
get more value from it and
Stream's in a unique position
to share data across the
enterprise and do it safely.
I think that's a key.
As we work with security teams,
the idea that, you know, here's
the pieces we can't share,
here's the pieces we can
and Stream gives that ability to do so.
I've really been impressed
with how sophisticated
Sophos has gotten and just
in being able to make sure
that they're maximizing
the value of their data.
'Cause then at the end of
the day, you have to go back
to your business and
show what's the point.
You gave me all this money,
how did I benefit the business?
How did I move the business
forward? How did I save money?
How did I enable new capabilities?
And when you start speaking
the language of business,
business leaders are much
more likely to invest in you,
invest in your program.
It's just really
important. Always remember,
you gotta move the
business forward every day.
- And one more thing on this slide,
actually, two more things.
Number one, there's
actually AI built into Cribl
where it keeps the operator
in the whole process here.
We're not gonna put
you through a black box
and say, "Hey look, magic's gonna happen."
We're gonna help guide the
operator to get their job done.
So the AI components allow operators
to build a proper pipeline
and you're right in the middle
to make sure it's done right,
to maybe write a natural
language query that makes sense
that you can actually pull data
and understand what the data is
that you're collecting in Cribl Lake.
So we have all of that.
And the best part about all of this
is that you can actually
try this out yourself today
with a free Cribl Cloud
tenant and, you know,
see the value for yourself
with your own data.
We do have a free tier up to
a terabyte of data per day.
So I wanna make sure
you remember that part.
- Yeah, we gotta remember
to say AI a lot too.
- Yes.
- I mean, look at
someone counting in the audience
how many times we say AI.
So we gotta, you know.
But that's part of the issue,
and I think this is something
I'm really pleased with,
Cribl's approach to AI.
How can you use AI to help your users
just get more value from the tooling?
Or the search interface is wonderful.
I owned a large searching platform
and had 5,000 people using it,
and keeping everyone
trained was a nightmare.
And so having AI in
place for a Cribl search,
the idea is, you have
your own personal helper
of how to find your data,
how to search your data,
suggest a better query,
a miracle upon miracle.
When you make a dashboard,
it's gonna help you make
an optimized dashboard by default.
You're not gonna have to know about
the magic of a base search.
And so these are the kind
of things that just help,
help just get more
value from your tooling.
And this is also, as
we're starting to roll out
more agentic workflows, to now
find the data that matters.
There's a background
helper that we're about
to load up into Stream
to help look for data
that might be of concern.
You know, AWS access keys, PAI, PHI,
all sorts of different
shapes of sensitive data
that you may not know are there.
It's just little by little
help solving these big problems
to help make you more productive
and at the end of the day,
get more value from your data.
- Yeah, one of my favorite
features by the way,
this is a little side note,
is within Cribl there's,
whenever you make a configuration
change, it's a Git repo
behind the scenes that gets updated.
Normally, it gives you a
little text box to say,
okay, go ahead and type out
exactly the changes you made.
Forget that. There's a little AI button
that you push that'll actually
tell you all the changes
that were made in that
configuration modification.
Puts it in the Git notes
or the commit notes
and there you go, simple
little things like that.
So that's six months from
now when someone goes back
and say, what changes happened here?
You actually have legit notes.
Not I configured Cribl, send.
It's actually something useful.
- I know. I spent years
yelling at my engineers
and code reviewers
about not writing notes,
and now you have a little
button. Makes it easy.
I mean they would literally
write me notes about, you know,
FU, because I'm not doing
this, you know, kind of thing.
So I mean these are the
ideas that, you know,
use AI to make your lives easier,
make the tools easier, and get more value,
and especially get it faster.
Let's talk about the outcomes.
And this is something I think was just...
and this is why Chris
did such an amazing job
with rolling out Cribl.
I mean 48% cost savings
within the first 30 days.
That's awesome.
And this is the idea, being
able to show your bosses,
you know, that dramatic rise in cost.
Here's how we can put fast, immediate,
and real controls around it.
And this is where a governance comes in,
'cause there's a whole
program to make sure
to look at your data.
Always look at your IT and security data.
It's changing, it's churning.
Make sure you understand that.
So constant looking, constant
reporting what's there.
Data independence was one
thing that really impressed
from a strategy standpoint that
Sophos implemented early on.
The idea from a first
principle standpoint,
we want our data to be portable.
We want it to be be useful,
we want it to be high quality.
And this is the idea.
Data independence I think is so important,
'cause too often with
the modern SIEM vendors,
you got a proprietary agent
talking a proprietary code
or protocol to a proprietary backend
that runs a proprietary search language.
The idea, by making all this
portable and independent,
now it's my data.
It's not my vendor's data, it's my data.
I can now have my data
inside of a data lake.
I can now use something like
Cribl Stream to do a replay
to put my data into Splunk,
Elastic, Databricks,
Snowflake, take your pick.
I can use that data anywhere I want to.
It's no longer stuck.
And so, I think it's a very powerful idea
is of how we can get more
value from your data,
bring the discipline
that you see all the time
in BI institutions of business value.
Bring that discipline over
into the IT and security side,
you can see enormous value.
This is where we started in governance.
Secure by design is something, I think,
Sophos is very proud of.
They spend a lot of time making
sure that their software,
their hardware are secure,
unlike some other vendors
that seem to make an RCE,
you know, a feature instead of a bug.
They're very careful about that.
And so that's something they
do early on by making sure
they're instrumenting
everything coming into Cribl.
And they're looking for
things all the time in order
to make sure everything we
release is secure by design.
And finally, the idea of, you know,
so we've talked about better data,
now we can maintain cost effectiveness.
So we're showing value but also
managing within our budget.
And that's very, very important.
- And one thing about cost effectiveness,
I just wanna kind of
double down on this one.
Typically, if you remember
the first chart I showed you
30% CAGR growth and it's,
you know, exponential.
One of the things that you're trying to do
with this data is you're
trying to basically make that,
you know, hockey stick chart
look a lot more manageable,
a lot more like your IT
budget where it's predictable
so you can be taking data
that you didn't get before,
your proxy logs, your DNS
logs, all those rich value
data sources that you're just can't afford
to put into your data destinations
actually affordable again.
So this is kind of a big win that you have
with something like Cribl.
- Yeah, and that's really important.
So I'm gonna double down even more.
The idea is that you're
rarely gonna have less,
you're rarely gonna have less.
So you have your established budget.
You're getting in trouble
because you're going 25% more every year.
If you can get it down to 5%
because most businesses accept,
there's gonna be 5, 6, 7,
8%, that's just unavoidable.
Thirty percent's a problem.
You're rarely gonna get to less.
And so the idea is flatten
out that cost curve
and that way you can then talk about
here's how we can get
more value from our data.
Collect the right data, control it,
but still maintain your costs.
- Absolutely.
- Yep.
- And now one of the most important things
I think most practitioners
here are gonna come for
is the lesson learned and
best practices for this.
So here's what Sophos was able to learn,
- Right, this is something I think
is important for everyone, have a plan.
You're not gonna get a single control plan
across all your data on day one.
Just not gonna do it.
Have a plan, a long term plan.
The idea of byte by byte,
we're gonna advance across the enterprise,
across every line of business
to have a consistent strategy
to collect your data.
It is always important.
Think long term.
You know, plan long term
and then and attack that
little by little because it
makes what would ordinarily be
an enormous project a lot more digestible.
And so this is one of the big lists.
It's important to have that visibility.
Imagine you have a data plane
across your entire
organization where I can see
where my data's coming from.
I can see where my data's going to.
I can detect if a data source is down.
I can detect if the
data source is degraded.
I mean anyone who's been
in any kind of incident
has figured out all of a sudden,
my data source stopped working,
it stopped working three months ago
and the only time you found out is
'cause now I need to look at it.
It's typically very difficult to monitor.
So having that centralized data plane
gives you a lot of options.
Filtering and optimizing data early,
I think, is important too
where this is also from
a long-term perspective.
And as you look at your data,
start building up a
long-term backlog of okay,
this is what we want to do with our data.
Here's what we can do.
Here's what we want to do.
One of the big struggles is,
especially with data that's being used,
is you gotta work with your users
to update your content
to reflect new formats.
And so you have to have
this careful planning
and communication process,
like I did with my team.
I had these thousands of users.
So we had communications of...
every couple of days we
started rolling out changes.
We notified our users,
we managed our risk,
and kept moving forward.
And so just make sure you
have a plan to do that.
Another big key as well,
and this is something I really appreciate
with Sophos going into
the data tiering is,
start looking at the
data you're not using.
I will guarantee you if
you look inside your SIEM,
you're gonna find 20, 25% of the data
that's not getting touched in 90 days.
That's the first thing you do.
If you're not using it,
don't put it in your SIEM.
Move it into your data lake
and now you freed up 25% of your SIEM,
and without any kind of disruption.
So just really look at that long term.
And I think that first
principle everyone talks about
with data tiering, is match cost to value.
Is the data worth the dollar
a gig? If it is, absolutely.
That's what the SIEM is for.
If it's not, put it somewhere else.
And finally, the phase migration approach,
which we've talked about.
Anything you wanna add?
- Yeah, I just wanted to say, you know,
on that data tiering piece.
- Yeah.
- You know,
most SIEMs are running
on very expensive disc
and without even talking about
license costs, the disc cost,
the people cost to get that
data in, it's not cheap.
And if you can save on those as well as,
you know, potentially a license help,
I think that's where you get
a real big win just long term.
- Yeah, we've seen this repeatedly.
Even with companies that
have an ELA for their SIEM,
for example, they're still saving
tens of millions of dollars
by moving data that they're
not using out of their SIEM.
And that's just from the
storage of compute cost alone.
Especially if you're
hosting yourself in cloud,
the costs are just astronomical
from an opus perspective.
So I always take a really hard look at...
and from a governor's
perspective every day,
understand what people are
using, what people are not using
in order to just have some controls there,
and then also, make it part
of your onboarding process.
You know, the idea that you
have to be able to say no.
Like, this data has no value,
we're not putting it in here.
This is where the governance
and policy process
is really key, to just
help provide answers.
'Cause otherwise you're
gonna drown in data,
you're gonna drown in cost
and eventually you're
gonna have that meeting
with your leadership, who aren't happy.
- And I will say this, when
you have a centralized approach
to this login solution, that
immediately gives you options.
That also gives you the little
more control of this data.
And you can make it
repeatable so that you,
the security operations
person, is not going in
and having to build these
pipelines, build these things.
You can actually push this down
to maybe the application owners.
So now they have the ability
with the tooling in place
to build these repeatable
processes to onboard applications,
onboard things on their own.
And so it becomes less of a
burden on you to do it, so.
- Yeah, and I think that's a big thing
as teams mature using Cribl's
tooling, be it the ability
to expand and become a
service owner becomes key.
And this is also, I encourage everyone,
it's not just a security solution,
it's also an IT and
observability solution.
Huge chunks of data.
And the thing is, I've seen
it, there's a lot of crossover.
Lots of security data
gets used by ops teams.
Lots of ops data gets
used by security teams.
And having it under a
common control mechanism
gives you a lot of power
and a lot of flexibility.
- Absolutely. Now let's take a look
at what the tool looks like.
- Yeah, this is really fun.
So this is the dashboard that Sophos uses.
So think of it as a heads up dashboard
to understand what's my
consumption is, are things working,
are we seeing load issues?
They have a much more detailed dashboard.
And this is something I encourage everyone
to take a look at Cribl Cloud.
We have a new product called Insights,
which is gonna give you a much more
expanded view of this data.
It's AI-driven and it's
also gonna give you
a lot broader view of your data.
And so this is a very
natural way of expanding
what we're doing with their data.
And so before, I mean
this is all very blind.
This is something Sophos
really struggled with.
It's something if a data source stopped,
they just typically didn't know about it
until they needed the data.
And so this is the idea is, you know,
how do we bring in this data?
How do we get this value?
And you can see the data coming in
versus the data going out.
And so they're able to
get just a lot of value,
you know, going forward.
- Great point. And obviously
this you can see on your own
Cribl Cloud tenant when you
go download and play with it,
right?
- Absolutely.
And this is something just really great.
So from the Cribl website,
you can get a free Cribl Cloud
tenant, click a few clicks,
you're gonna have the full suite.
So that's gonna be Lake,
that's gonna be Search, Edge, and Stream.
We also have options for
what we call our sandboxes.
So sandbox.cribl.io, where
click another button,
you can have a guided use case
through using the actual
tools that are hosted in AWS.
So you can get an idea,
does this make sense for me.
Try to address this so you
have several use cases.
That's the big thing, does it make sense?
You wanna get your hands on the product?
No one's gonna bother you.
You're not gonna have to
go through sales to get it.
You will be able to get access.
You just want to be able
to put this out there
and make it as easy as possible.
So this is really fun.
And so the idea of first
we talk about is...
we have what's called a route.
So as data's flowing through the system,
it's flowing through the system,
starts from the top to the bottom,
you're now looking for a filter
and you can see where
the idea that we're using
looking for user off events
and we're now gonna redirect
any event that contains this string,
we're gonna put this into a pipeline.
Do you have anything
you wanna add about...
Common, like best practices?
- Yeah, I mean for the most part,
when you start with Cribl you'll see,
oh, you know, filter equals true.
So you're basically all your data.
But as you start to get refined
and understand how to properly
route the data based on
what you need, you can
start building your filters.
One of the best features
of Cribl, which is what
kind of sold me when I was
kind of coming to Cribl,
is the fact that they have helper buttons
on each one of these steps.
It'll actually pull in the
documentation, still have the UI,
but I have the documentation
sitting right next to you.
So it can actually do, you know,
"Oh, how do I do a JavaScript
filter in regular expression?
Here's how I do that."
So very, very helpful.
- And one thing I wanna point out of this,
and this is something that's common.
So Sophos drives from this
one route, drive detections,
drive audit, drive compliance,
and so that's that idea
that I'm looking for pieces.
And this is something I
think is misunderstood.
You see a lot of times like
we're gonna do detections of the Stream.
More often than not, what you're doing is,
is you're picking out interesting data
and highlighting, this may be important
in order to stitch it together
on the back end of your SIEM.
And that's one of the
thing Sophos has done
a really nice job of finding
those interesting events
and then raising the
visibility to their SOC
with their new backend SIEM tool.
But then from an auto perspective,
they're now retaining it,
driving it into their analytics platform.
So now they can query it
and understand it from a higher level.
And the idea is, you don't have
to do this all in one place.
And this is, I think, the perfect example
of breaking it apart and
making it more service-based
to give you more flexibility.
- And here you can basically
see kind of the progression.
They're adding multiple routes,
they're adding multiple kind of filters
so that they can properly
diagnose the data,
send it down to the right
pipeline, leveraging PACS,
which we'll get to in a minute,
which kind of just helps
accelerate the adoption
of these data sources that
also make it repeatable.
- And one of the cool things
that they're doing as well is
they're pulling data
for their next firewall.
They're now adding an enrichment to it.
I think it's a very
underappreciated part of
a better data story.
As data comes through,
let's make it better.
Let's add context to it.
And one thing I did, this
is from an IT perspective,
is we started adding in playbook.
So we had a well-recognized
error message we would add in.
By using a lookup, we'd add
in a link to the wiki playbook
that then the NOC team
would use to then react.
And we did the same thing with security.
So we're always, how
do we make data better?
How do we make 'em more actionable?
And this is a really great
look at how they're doing
it with their firewall tool.
And you can see as it's coming through,
that you're now you're sharing data.
And so the idea is, so start with the top
and then this notice that...
there's a little button called final.
And that's the idea is, once
the data hits the right filter,
it's finalized, it doesn't follow through.
One of the fun things you can always do is
as you especially just share
data, is flip the final flag.
So now the copy of the data
falls to the next route.
And that's how you enable
the ability to share.
Imagine where you start
with my first route goes
to my object storage, my
second route goes to my SIEM,
my third route goes say say at Kafka.
So that's the way you can
put the same events in three
different places and have full
control over where it goes.
And so this is something that
the very amount, high volume,
this is a great example of this
with this pipeline in particular.
They were able to get
something like 60% reduction
by just making a simple change about
how they managed the data
and how they classified it.
- Yeah. Always very powerful.
- Yeah. And look and look at the way now
you're structuring your data.
So this is a good example
of how from the idea of...
I always wanna talk about
detection engineering
as being the end result
of good data engineering.
But what you're seeing here is,
now Sophos has chopped up an event,
they've added structure to it.
And this is also one
of the fun things that,
depending upon the backend SIEM vendor,
you can actually accelerate
these fields as well
by doing this.
So not only do we get a better
format, it's more searchable,
typically it's gonna be smaller,
it's also gonna be more consistent.
This is something that...
Sophos didn't do this,
but also I encourage you
to consider fixing your
timestamp here as well.
- Oh my gosh. Yeah.
- Yeah, normalizing your
timestamp is very, very powerful.
And so just the idea of
every time you run into
a data problem, this is
where you look to fix it.
- One of my favorite stories
around the timestamps.
We were talking to an executive
for a very large security firm
and they came to us, says,
why do we need Cribl?
And clearly I was like, "Have you ever had
an issue with a timestamp?
Do you know that people don't
always use UTC use time zones?
And when you go look for an event,
hey magically it didn't exist until you do
either all time or you
go look in the future.
Oh look there's the event.
What's it doing out there?"
- Yeah, yeah. I'll never forget the...
I get called to a bridge
and their new application
that they had deployed in
Central Asia wasn't showing up
and the data was exactly
11 and a half hours off
to the millisecond.
And you know, looking at the
data, looking at the data
and you know, an hour
later it suddenly hits me
that the developers had hard coded
the central standard
time zone into the log
into something that was deployed in India.
And so that was the kind
of thing where this,
you know, timestamp controls
are really important.
So after that, I never trusted
a timestamp ever again.
And so the idea that the
data's coming through Cribl,
the idea is I'm gonna fix the timestamp,
I gonna fix the time zone
and then I'm gonna alert
me that there's a problem.
'Cause it's just a fundamental issue
of you always need better
data to solve problems
and like time zones,
timestamps are still the devil.
- I mean, I can keep talking
about this for a little bit.
There's one customer that
I had back in the day
where their developers
had 15 different ways
of doing timestamps.
Literally 15 different timestamps.
So yeah, good luck
finding that in your logs.
- Exactly. And so these are key things
and I think one also wanna mention
that from a detection engineer,
they're actually ripping
apart the output of netstat.
If you're looking at netstat
as part of standard out,
you wouldn't think that was something
that was very easy to structure.
But this is an example by
essentially running the script,
you get the output and by
using this exact same template,
they were able to get the
structure they needed,
make it repeatable, and get a...
'cause there's so much you can do
with that kind of data once
it's structured correctly.
- So this is part of
the kind of conversation
where we're having like
question and answer.
I'll skip this just to
show one more thing here.
We'll definitely have a question
and answer section here.
But really quickly, just
wanted to reiterate the fact
that Cribl has our university training,
which is free training and certification.
You can go get it, you can
go tell your friends about it
and you can also get these certifications
that employers are actually
asking for these days.
It blew my mind.
It's Cribl, both of us were very early on,
and when we saw that
people, like companies,
are actually saying, "Hey, we
need a Cribl level one admin
or engineer level
certification to get this job
or to apply for this job." Blew my mind.
And I was so proud to see that.
- Well I mean it was just free training.
That blew my mind.
I mean, as a customer I spent
hundreds of thousands of
dollars and additional money
paying to learn how to use
tools I'd already paid for.
And so I was just like, "Really"?
I mean that sounds like
too good of an idea.
And I've seen...
I know with your customers
you see the same thing.
- Oh yeah.
- The idea that Cribl, we
try to look at the idea is
the better you know how to use the tools,
the better results you're gonna get,
you know, the better their relationship.
And I think that's the way
it should be for everyone.
I think training is everything.
- And our docs are also
not behind the paywall.
- Yeah, that too.
- Always a big win.
- Right. And also from the AI perspective,
you can always ask Copilot
and the Copilot will
look up the docs for you.
- Yep.
- So it's really nice.
And we already mentioned sandboxes.
Sandboxes are a great
piece because it's just...
you know, you wanna talk
about data reduction, routing,
you wanna click about, you know,
putting data in object
storage, it's all right there.
You're gonna have a really nice rich way
of walking through it, and
get hands on right away.
Just, you know, a 10-minute investment
in order to try all these
different use cases out.
- Yep.
- Thank you for coming
and we're gonna be here for a little bit,
so if you have any
questions, please come by.
- Yes. Thanks so much.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)